right let's get started hi guys if you
want to know how to learn a language we
felt killing yourself
stay with me welcome everybody thank you
for joining today's webinar on how to
learn in language without killing
yourself this is actually a riri
recording of the webinar because we had
some technical issues and don't worry
this recording will be even better
because we will cover even more content
here so before we get started let me
introduce you myself shortly my name is
Stefan I'm an Austrian Korean living in
Vienna and working as a researcher and
PhD candidate at the Department for East
Asian Studies at the University of
Vienna and exactly one year ago I found
that the on consulate how to become a
professor calm in which I interview
proven professors and experts on
accelerated learning so much my person
but now it's time to introduce you to
our today's teacher and coach his name
is Luca and Perriello Lukas an Italian
polyglot from Rome who speaks 12
languages he's become well known a
well-known personality within the
language community not only for his
incredible language skills but for his
capacity to transmit his knowledge and
expertise on how to learn a language
more efficiently
so welcome Luca Hey I - thank you for
the lovely presentation yeah ok long
time no see
alright ok so this is the agenda for
today's recording of the webinar during
the first 30 minutes Luke is going to
provide actionable content on following
topics how to learn a language in your
limited spare time secondly how to stick
to a painless and efficient learning
routine and third how to learn a
language from scratch after the 30
minutes in the second half of the
webinar we will answer the questions
your questions that came up during the
webinar these are how to learn more than
one language at the same time how to
build vocab how to learn Asian languages
specific specifically in Chinese and
Japanese and how to improve your
confidence in speaking and lastly how to
use textbooks and other language
resources in the most efficient
and at the end of the session this is
really important we will make a special
announcement that might be of interest
for you so please stay tuned until the
end it's really worth it
all right Luka are you ready yeah I'm
ready
all right okay to warm you up a little
bit please share with everybody your
personal language story how are you how
were you able to become functionally
fluent in 12 languages I started
learning languages at the age of 10 when
I was in middle school I started
learning English and French but I have
to say that I didn't learn much at
school because the Italian school system
as many other school systems is not very
efficient insofar as language learning
is concerned so what happened at the age
of 12 my parents finally decided to hire
a private tutor she she is American and
I started learning with her so by taking
private lessons at the same time I kept
learning French at school in general I
was watching a lot of television but it
was only at the age of 15 that I
actually came actually found the way of
my way to learn languages
and I tried to when I try to tackle
German at the beginning was a little bit
difficult because especially you know
German is not an easy language
especially for us Italians grammar is
pretty complicated etc so I what I did I
tried to get hold of a dusty hold
grammar book that my my grandma had and
I tried to learn grammar so I started
with with this grammar approach but I
very soon I just figured out that it
didn't work for me so I I started using
a course which is called Agostini and I
found a way to apply to to use it you
know suitable way for me and what
happened is that I started learning
quickly and I realized that learning a
language by yourself can be actually
much faster than just learning it in
institutions schools and Jura City
provided that you know how to do it
after that after I figured out a way to
work with languages and to work on
languages I learned Spanish and then I
learned Dutch and
Swedish Russian etc etc and I decided to
learn one language every two years
because I think that a lot of people
talk about learning languages but
keeping languages is maintaining
languages is also very important so in
the course of time I thought that this
was a very sound strategy to keep
learning but at the same time and
maintaining the knowledge and the
languages to attend that it was there
was accumulating that I was learning at
third time and Here I am